Peggy's 16
so with tyranny we wanted to go with a
more stylized view for our characters
environments it sort of has a nostalgic
element it also has an element of the
new as well so our environment artists
they really push themselves to build
some really unique environments that
you've never seen before if we wanted to
create a world where you could see the
history and the age in every scene in
every piece of armor you have to
showcase that evil has one so there's
destruction there's chaos not happy
colors we wanted to take the
environments and still make them a place
you really want to explore that's war
torn and oppressed but with the art
style we try to create a little bit of
levity with that makes feel like a place
where people driven by real human intent
and emotions could actually live
there are lots of characters there's all
the companions all the archons sit
disfavor the innocent bystanders the
armies and I try to make each one of
those its own special character I would
love to say that I art directed that but
this is one of those moments where you
allow an artist to be creative and they
give you something back that's more than
expected look at that dude art works
pretty closely with the narrative to you
they would allow us a lot of room to
expand the characters in our own way
tell like a lot about a person from just
a glimmer behind their eyes and so
that's something I really try to go
after first I would talk to narratives
and be like what is the backstory of
this guy what made him who he is today
and we get a description like for Seiran
who's a 16 year old opera singer in
Google like opera singer like no not
that one that's not right we can't find
any reference we would then act out the
reference we have to hundreds and tons
of shield but most interesting human
dicket's to do and our game would be the
beast men because they're just so unique
I bought I like a pair of whole whoops
but those suckers aren't started running
around the office or running around
outside we made quite a scene the reason
why we didn't use mocap is because it
would just look too much candy for the
world that we're in so for us because
everything was so stylized like it hit
stronger poses and just push reality
more than we went through motion capture
I don't want to create generic
characters I want to make these
characters feel unique to each other
what I'm most interested in when I'm
writing the music forest score is the
people that live in this world that
inhabit this world because that's really
what gives it its humanity the game had
the potential to sort of veer into very
heavy territory and we wanted to avoid
that with the music wherever possible so
it's sort of this cognitive dissonance
where we've created music that by itself
can be considered beautiful
and it's juxtaposed with this pretty
evil guy you know or a girl that was
really important because we don't want
the player to necessarily feel
overburdened by all these very heavy
decisions we wanted them to feel like
they could play this game for hours on
end when I look at tyranny the things
that I really love about it I love the
art style I think it's very different
from what we perform it's a pretty vast
world we wanted to have a little more
fun with shape let's go there's a lot of
really interesting ingredients in the
narrative and in the visual look of the
world so you should fill either at home
if you're an evil character you should
come out of your place if you're a
person writing for good
you